[Musica]
c'è una leggenda metropolitana che dice
che un anno nel mondo cripto equivale a
cinque anni nel mondo fisico
io sono un artista fisico un pittore è
un artista cripto digitale
nel mondo fisico realizzo dipinti in
acrilico e sculture in stampa 3d e nel
mondo cripto video fatti con programmi
di animazione grafica
il centro della mia ricerca artistica è
la riscoperta del bambino interiore
attraverso il recupero di memorie
emotive per tornare a recuperare queste
memorie emotive facce dei viaggi nel
passato usando la meditazione
un essere umano cresce diventa adulto e
dimentica il centro stesso della sua
esistenza perché vive una vita in
preoccupazione preoccupazione
prima dopo domani ieri mai adesso
la mia ispirazione arriva dal mondo
degli anime manga giapponesi
che hanno contaminato e formato tutta la
mia arte tutta la mia estetica
se dovessi dare un confine al mio mondo
fantastico
potrei dire di appartenere la corrente
neo pop
e tra i vari ingredienti il fatto che il
più alto numero di persone possibili
possano entrare in contatto col mio
lavoro anche possedere non solo
pezzettino è per me di fondamentale
importanza
facciamo un passo indietro che cos'è un
bambino e che cos'è una memoria emotiva
un bambino è un essere umano in grado di
vivere il presente l'attimo che scorre
esattamente il momento in cui esiste non
c'è futuro non c'è passato solo adesso
quindi se sei in grado se riesce a
esercitare la presenza puoi metterti in
contatto col tutto attorno a te dentro
di te
la memoria emotiva non è altro che uno
strumento che ti permette di tornare
indietro nel passato recuperare memoria
stati d'animo dimenticati sentimenti
emozioni
offuscati se riesce a fare questo se
riesce a tornare a recuperarli hai la
possibilità di metterti in contatto col
tuo bambino o bambina
addormentato nascosto
vi faccio un esempio
se hai in tasca una molletta per capelli
e questa molletta te l'ha regalata tua
figlia
enel dartela ci ha appoggiato sopra un
bacio ed ha detto ti amo
e poi questa molletta tu la dai a me per
me è un oggetto serve per tenere i
capelli ma per te le cose sono cambiate
non seppi disposto né a venderla né a
cederla
e quando tra 20 30 anni la ritroverà in
un cassetto in una tasca di una giacca
non sarà di nuovo un oggetto perché ci
attaccata una memoria emotiva l'oggetto
è carico di energia
tutto questo per dire cosa questo è il
punto di partenza di un artista fisico
come me ce ne sono molti altri che si
sono dovuti costruire una carriera una
credibilità una storia nel mondo
dell'arte classica contemporanea che non
è altro che un sistema un sistema che al
delle regole dei protagonisti quindi
galleria artista
collezionista critico curatore museo
fiera e questo sistema esercita una
forza potentissima che parte dall'alto
che prende l'artista e lo porta più o
meno è successo
e poi
arriva la cripta arte
un'autentica rivoluzione
che parte da molto lontano ma solamente
negli ultimi anni grazie alla tecnologia
della block cei ha permesso a un file di
essere unico
e nel momento in cui un oggetto e in
questo caso un oggetto digitale diventa
unico c'è qualcuno nel mondo che lo
vuole possedere lo vuole
collezionare lo brama
e quindi nasce un mercato con nuove
regole e nuovi protagonisti quindi
programmato rianimatori grafici
direttori creativi registi che fino a
ieri avevano collaborato con per fare
progetti alle dipendenze di qualcun
altro si ritrovano ad avere del
materiale da esporre da vendere
e si ritrovano all'improvviso senza una
formazione accademico artistica ad
essere artisti
la cripto arte non è altro che un
avanguardia
e come tutte le avanguardie e mossa da è
spinta da una forza energica arrogante
cattiva aggressiva vigorosa potentissima
che spinge dal basso verso l'alto
e su cosa ci appoggia
si appoggia su una comunità una comunità
di persone
che vivono del web e comunica a tutti i
giorni attraverso i social
parlano si confrontano e alla velocità
della luce sviluppano nuovi progetti
nuove tecnologie e quindi
ve la do io un'idea del futuro
personalissima mia vi faccio fare un
esercizio di immaginazione
immaginatevi un centinaio di studenti
del liceo artistico o dell'accademia
d'arte 14 18 anni davanti all'ingresso
il primo giorno di lezione
e all'ingresso c'è un tavolo sinistra
c'è una penna ottica un visore 1q luz e
a destra c'è una matita un blocco di
carta e un pennello
e in centro un cartello con su scritto
scegli la tua via quanti sceglieranno
l'uno e l'altra ve la do io una stima 90
10 92 8 95 595 sceglieranno la penna
ottica e 5 sceglieranno il pennello nei
prossimi 15 anni la stragrande
maggioranza delle nuove generazioni di
artisti saranno nativi digitali
cambieranno modelli espositivi
curatoriali cambierà tutto
e quindi
e quindi ci sarà sempre un artista
fisico che vorrà morire con la matita in
mano e ci sarà sempre un artista
digitale che penserà che un pennello è
un oggetto vintage e poi ci sono io
artista fisico e cristo e come me molti
altri artisti fisici e critto che
abbiamo un compito abbiamo un dovere
abbiamo una responsabilità dobbiamo far
comunicare i due mondi dobbiamo farli
parlare dobbiamo essere un ponte tra uno
e l'altro e come si fa
beh servono gli ingredienti di base
talento
grandi abilità tecniche grandi capacità
di comunicazione
grandi capacità di organizzazione e poi
serve un ingrediente 1 sempre quello
sopra tutti gli altri la passione e la
passione è un'astrazione come tutte le
astrazioni a un suo ingrediente
specifico
la passione brucia forte all'inizio e
col tempo tende a consumarsi
sapete qual è il bello di tutta questa
storia cui adesso è che siamo all'inizio
viva l'arte è viva gianni voi
[Applauso]
[Musica]